[Música]
unos 40 migrantes la mayoría de
venezolanos desembarcaron frente a la
residencia de la vicepresidenta de eeuu
kamala harris enviados en autobuses por
el gobernador de texas previamente el
gobernador de florida se responsabilizó
por el envío de otros venezolanos al
exclusivo balneario de martha's vineyard
los republicanos buscan responsabilizar
a los demócratas por influjo migratorio
el centro nacional de huracanes de eeuu
prevé que la tormenta tropical fiona se
convierta en huracán mientras se dirigía
a puerto rico- después de devastar la
isla de guadalupe entretanto al otro
lado del planeta japón activó la máxima
alerta ante la llegada del super tifón
nanmadol que podría ser el más
destructivo que azota al país asiático
en décadas
a dos semanas de las elecciones
presidenciales en brasil los candidatos
buscan apoyo en los territorios de sus
oponentes el presidente ya ir bolsonaro
viajó al estado natal de su rival el ex
presidente luiz inácio lula da silva
mientras que el líder izquierdista viajó
hasta paraná que apoyó a bolsonaro en
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz
empezamos en eeuu este sábado llegaron
tres nuevos autobuses con migrantes
venezolanos a nueva york y otro frente a
la residencia de la vicepresidenta
kamala harris provenientes de texas por
decisión del gobernador republicano greg
abbott que busca como otros mandatarios
republicanos poner presión en
territorios mayoritariamente demócratas
culpando a estos del flujo migratorio
que entre eeuu el jueves el gobernador
de florida también republicano envió a
decenas de venezolanos al prestigioso
balneario de la isla de martha's
vineyard en massachusetts los demócratas
califican esta nueva crisis migratoria
como una jugada política de los
republicanos
samuel salgado nos tienen los detalles
de una imagen insólita después de 40
horas en autobús decenas de venezolanos
les embarcan sorprendidos frente a la
residencia de la vicepresidenta de eeuu
kamala harris imágenes que simbolizan la
más reciente disputado y partidista
este autobús como otros que han llegado
a washington y nueva york y dos aviones
que aterrizaron en el balneario
exclusivo de martha's vineyard son parte
de una campaña de gobernadores
republicanos como los de texas y florida
que buscan mostrar el presunto fracaso
de las políticas migratorias de los
demócratas enviando a los migrantes a
circunscripciones donde estos son
mayoritarias las comunidades y las ong
se solidarizan con los migrantes quienes
a menudo se sorprenden de adónde los han
enviado los estamos trasladando ahora
mismo a un lugar seguro donde podamos
darles comida un espacio para descansar
y una muda de ropa limpia
los demócratas señalan a los
republicanos tras esta decisión brain
abbott cobre orden texas y ron de santis
de florida de hacer una jugada política
previa a las elecciones de medio término
de noviembre
algunos residentes en el balneario
veraniego de martha's vineyard se
solidarizan con esta idea es realmente
molesto estas pobres personas han sido
utilizadas y realmente lo siento por
ellos los migrantes asentados en la isla
fueron trasladados a una base militar
cercana en que code nueva york recibió
tres buses con migrantes provenientes de
texas este sábado muchos de ellos
venezolanos expresan alivio de estar por
fin en territorio estadounidense por ser
un holograma de puede pasar tanto tiempo
méxico jaume pasando méxico porque lo
logramos según la organización
internacional de las migraciones en lo
corrido 2022 han sido interceptados más
de un millón de emigrantes la tormenta
tropical fiona dejó al menos un muerto
tras su paso por la isla francesa de
guadalupe en el caribe que sigue en
alerta roja por lluvias intensas y
tormentas eléctricas y que ha registrado
muchos daños materiales el gobernador de
puerto rico solicitó a eeuu a emitir una
declaración de emergencia por la
tormenta que se espera se convierte en
huracán de categoría 1 al llegar a la
isla
fuentes arrasados casas inundadas y
devastación así quedó la isla francesa
de guadalupe en el caribe tras el paso
de la tormenta tropical fiona en alerta
roja por fuertes lluvias y tormentas
eléctricas
este es el puente degollaba el río se lo
ha llevado si ve su altura en relación
con el agua el nivel del agua debió
subir al menos 35 metros invadió todo el
valle e inundó las casas de la gente
con las lluvias excepcionales desde el
viernes han hecho subir el nivel del
agua hasta un metro y medio y han
provocado cortes de luz y agua en la
región y otras fallas en los sistemas
que han afectado a al menos 10.000
usuarios como en el caso de estela del
hongo que ahora intenta sacar el agua de
su casa tras la explosión de un contado
y los despertaron a las dos de la mañana
porque el contador explotó así que nos
levantamos y vimos que el agua empezaba
a subir en casa tiene una hora teníamos
80 centímetros de agua dentro
de
este archipiélago de las antillas
menores ya había sufrido inundaciones a
finales de abril que dejaron al menos un
muerto y estado de catástrofe natural en
varios municipios con fenómenos cada vez
más recurrentes que los expertos achacan
a la crisis climática ahora con este
nuevo temporal el gobierno local ha
instado a los ciudadanos a permanecer en
sus casas y se han suspendido la mayoría
de las actividades ya que se espera que
el fenómeno meteorológico formado en la
cuenca del atlántico no termine hasta el
domingo en la mañana
haití cumple casi una semana de
violentas protestas luego del anuncio
del primer ministro ariel en hey de
aumentar el precio de la gasolina y
otros combustibles miles de personas se
han manifestado en puerto príncipe y
otras ciudades del país exigiendo la
renuncia del mandatario a través de su
cuenta de twitter el ministro de
justicia condenó los saqueos y
vandalismo contra instituciones públicas
e internacionales empresas privadas así
como las residencias de dirigentes
políticos y ciudadanos pacíficos
y continúan las denuncias y las
tensiones en nicaragua por el arresto a
opositores al gobierno de daniel ortega
el centro nicaragüense de derechos
humanos denunció que la administración
de ortega está tomando como rehenes a
familiares de sus detractores con el fin
de obligarlos a que entreguen a sus
parientes para el organismo las
detenciones de familiares desvinculados
de la política superan la gravedad
delictiva del secuestro extorsivo que
según el código penal es cuando se exige
un rescate o cualquier utilidad
monetaria
y en brasil sigue la campaña
presidencial de cara a la primera vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales que se
celebrarán en dos semanas esta vez los
candidatos buscan apoyo en los
territorios de sus oponentes el
presidente ayer bolsonaro visito
pernambuco estado natal de su rival el
ex presidente luiz inácio lula da silva
y donde en los comicios de 2018 obtuvo
sólo el 35 por ciento de los votos
desde ayer reiteró sus creencias
conservadoras lula por su parte viajó
hasta la ciudad de curitiba en el estado
de paraná en el que bolsonaro resultó
victorioso en las pasadas elecciones
allí acusó al mandatario de no entender
cómo funciona el país
nuestra familia es sagrada defenderemos
la verdadera familia no queremos
legalizar las drogas en brasil
los dedos
[Aplausos]
no queremos legalizar el aborto en
brasil
[Música]
no admitimos la ideología de género para
nuestros hijos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
todo el mundo sabe que evolucionaron no
entiende de educación no entiende de
empleo no entiende de sindicatos no
entiende de enfermería no entiende
absolutamente nada excepto noticias
falsas
y mentira la sociedad va sileña como lo
hace todos los días
y cerramos en argentina al ritmo del
tango porque la capital de este país
acogió la edición número 19 del mundial
de baile de este género
[Música]
55 parejas compitieron en la gala de
finales en dos categorías tango de pista
cuyos ganadores fueron cynthia palacios
y sebastián bolívar y tango escenario en
la que se alzaron con el galardón
constanza pietro y ricardo a estrada
[Música]
de esta manera despedimos a este
informativo en france 24 gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]